[Music]  hey everyone listen listen okay  I saw a monster it came to me from out  of the sky then I thought a mythical  creature I have only heard exist in  legend no I did  no I saw it doesn't exist can't this  ridiculous story and tell the truth I am  telling the truth  we believe you Nicci  welcome to the SES stands for small food  exists sucker we have been collecting  proof of the small foots existence  behold the scroll of invisible wisdom  imagine of the basic stuff they put on  here this proves nothing  I know what I saw I'm gonna prove it  wait he's gone  [Music]  I should introduce myself small foot oh  that's supposed to fall out like that  [Music]  [Music]